From This Moment
I mean I did think I would never sing
again
not because I was giving up I was
running out of options according to the
experts
like fixing this
it's almost like the heart of the
challenge the more fight I have in me I
have to step up to the plate and I have
to
find the courage I gotta find it I've
gotta dig for it I just kept trying and
you know what I made it through and here
I am showing the new music and the fans
embracing my new
you know recording voice
because this is the first record since
my operation
so whatever voice is there is my newest
voice it's not a lot of power
more than before my surgery
you know a lot more
um I can get very loud
I'm enjoying singing again I'm enjoying
being in front of people I'm never
quitting music I am thriving I'm
celebrating
Shania will be celebrating with her fans
when her World Tour kicks off April 28th
her first new album in almost six years
queen of me out tomorrow ushers in
herself proclaimed fun era she says
writing it during the pandemic felt like
therapy I was using songwriting to pick
up my spirits to take charge of my mood
and I was bent on staying positive
[Music]
one word like that popped into my mind
when I was listening to all the tracks
like freedom and not only do we hear it
from you we see it with the artwork so I
decided that I would do a nude photo
shoot
and face my fears head on like in the
most terrifying way you can imagine
right
crew around yeah life's full blast on no
no escaping it and it really worked it
really I threw my fear out the window
I did not tiptoe in there I owned it I
took it to the Limit hence queen of me
is uh you know it's like okay I'm the
boss in me take charge of your of your
Liberty
of your freedom right self-empowerment
in general what would you say is the
most important thing for you at this
phase in your life when it comes to
taking care of your body I like to be
mindful of what I'm eating and I love
listen I love french fries if you love
spicy marks like just give me a night of
spicy margaritas and seasoned french
fries I'm good
[Music]
the last time that you and I spoke I
asked you like what do we have to do to
get a Harry Styles collaboration
everyone on the planet even if they
don't admit it wants to sing with Harry
Styles I was lucky enough to already do
that maybe he can come join you on stage
during the tour it'll be so good well I
do have a dream I do love his song
Falling Again
[Music]
so if I did that I'd do it with him on
that that would be awesome recently
joked that Ryan Reynolds doesn't impress
you okay so you're Ryan Reynolds that
don't historically Brad Pitt has not
impressed you who does impress Shania
Twain well both of them do this is my I
mean you know Brad Pitt I mean he's like
of course he's he's very impressed and
Ryan Reynolds
which I mean my fellow Canadian he can
do no wrong so of course he's the
perfect Target for that don't impress me
much the perfect Target adorable a
lovely lovely man and so talented that
don't impress me
foreign